[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حقبه جديده من المواجهه بين الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب وخصومه
والقضاء تبدا مع نشر التقرير النهائي
للجنه التحقيق في مجلس النواب بشان احداث
السادس من يناير
يوصي بان ينظر الكونجرس في منع ترامب من
توله منصبا عاما مره اخرى لدوره التحريضي
على التمرد يومها مؤكدا خياطه بشكل اجرامي
في مؤامره متعدده الاجزاء لقلب نتائج
الانتخابات وفشله في التصرف لمنع مؤيد من
مهاجمه مبنى الكابتل
الحزب الجمهوري حيث من المحتمل ان يقول
الكثير من الجمهوريين انهم يحبون ترامب
لكن لديه الكثير من المشاكل هو غير مرشح
لا يفوز مثل مرشحين اخرين
لكن ورغم ان توصيات اللجنه غير ملزمه
لوزاره العدل التي تقرروني اجابتها العامه
البث في توجيه التهامه ينظر العديد اليها
على انها خارطه طريق للعداله لكن من دون
جدول زمنيا واضح
في منصبه ولا يملك اي من مزايا كونه رئيسا
للولايات المتحده ويخضع الى حد كبير لنطاق
كونه قيد التحقيق وربما يواجه اتهاما
جنائيا من قبل وزاره العدل
وكان جمهوريون في مجلس الشيوخ اعلن هو بعد
توصيات اللجنه بتوجيه التهم الى ترامب
انهم لا يحمونه خاصه حلفاء زعيمهم في
المجلس الذي قال ان الامه باكملها تعرف من
المسؤول عن الهجوم في اشاره الى ترامب
الذي اتهم اللجنه بالسعي لمنعه من الترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
التي يح وفيها نظام العداله الجنائيه
الامريكيه مرشحا رئاسيا ورئيسا سابقا لهذا
يرى خبراء ان ذلك عبئا على الوزاره لكي
تقوم بهذه السابقه ما قد يجعلها تتردد قبل
اتخاذ القرار حسين الطاوض العربيه